jay-j wanted to meet with me we met up
at a cafe in town and I remember sitting
reading on his iPhone the new Star Wars
movie while he was just sitting in front
of millions of cafe in Paris it was just
incredibly surreal dry yeah that was
with Nick ref and we meant had a no host
star I went to that restaurant there and
I was actually coming to tell him that I
wasn't going to do the movie when I had
read the script I remember feeling that
the character of standard was standard
when he said well if it could be
anything you wanted what what would it
be what would it be if you could just
because make it up and so then we sat
there in for four hours I remember in
this restaurant and we just went through
it and just kind of spit balled and came
up with all these ideas of like well
what if he was owning his own bar and he
you know decided to me he made a mistake
because he kept some money that he
shouldn't have and now he's in jail and
now he then he's got stuff has to pay
for protection and slowly this whole
thing just spirals and spirals out of
his control
and I think ultimately it made it just a
much more complex situation because
suddenly you did feel a little bit for
the guy and so once he comes out of
prison you know suddenly this triangle
gets much more complex says you've been
coming around helping out a lot all
right mm-hmm
that's very nice listen I see thank you
I also remember onset just Nicolas F&E
would always wear a blanket around his
midsection because that's where he kept
the energy warm it was from Nick
raffinate and I can't keep this with me
all the time now because he says he's
like you know whenever it says in the
script the guy comes through the door
I wonder why doesn't it why doesn't he
come through the window or up through
the floor break through a wall and and
so he kind of goes through all the
different choices of what it's not to
get back to why it has to be this one
and that's something that I've always
kind of kept with me that idea of like
well what else could it possibly be
inside Llewyn Davis that was the kind of
the thing that changed everything I
remember I was doing a movie in
Pittsburgh and I was pretty bored and so
I started just playing a lot of guitar
I'd always played a guitar but this time
I just really became much more serious
about it and I started finding open mics
in the area and I would go and I'd play
and then a few months later I get this
audition for the Coen Brothers where I
had to play some songs Oh everything
that happened to get to this part was
just so crazy like I was then I was
doing this other film after I knew that
I had the audition coming up and there
was a guy that was a featured extra he's
an old guy the end of the bar and there
was a guitar laying around and he picked
up the guitar and he started playing it
exactly in this style was Travis picking
and he was amazing he was so good it
seems Eric France and I said hi you're
amazing yeah you play a lot like oh yeah
I've been playing all my life do you
give lessons yeah actually give lessons
all the time and I said oh because I'm
gonna audition for this thing that's
kind of based on Dave Van ronk cuz you
know Dave Van ronk he's like yeah I
played with Dave and so I get chills I
need to learn how to play can you yeah
yeah so I go to his place and he lives
right above the old Gaslight he's been
there for years and it looked like a
time capsule we had to all these old
guitars everywhere in records and he
just sort of playing a record after
record and teaching me how to play in
this Travis ping this is just for the
audition you know I haven't even gotten
the part yet then I got it and and
and it was the most incredible
experience my life they cool stone I
don't see a lot of money here you know
Jonathan they kind of always operate
from this place of whoever feels the
strongest wins someone feels very
strongly that that shouldn't be the shot
they'll always be one guy that's like no
it definitely shouldn't be that the
other guy he's like alright cool and
every once in a while likely to come up
and you know Joel would come to give me
a direction and he'd leave and then he
thought would come to give me direction
sometimes it was a different direction
so I would just do what the last guy
said the whole thing was just like the
biggest education I could possibly ever
get her just so generous with like their
knowledge and at the same time didn't
give any compliments so that kind of
really taught me to really just just
stay within myself and not to look for
anything from them because whenever
they'd come up you know it's like if it
was good they just come and go yeah yeah
you know and then if it wasn't good to
go yeah yeah I got it I got it
do it again the most violent year that
was particularly cool because it was
right down the street from where I live
where mostly where we were shooting so I
could just walk to work every morning it
was also the coldest winter in years and
years you know underneath that big camel
coat and those you know perfect Armani
suits I was wearing you know of
flesh-coloured diving suit to keep me
warm and that was really great
particularly because of Jessica Chastain
who I went to school with and we went to
Julliard together and she's the one that
really can kind of championed me for the
role you know I remember it was like a
very you know debonair very
well-put-together guy and at this at the
time I was just finishing shooting ex
machina and when when I met with JC I
was I had a shaved head and a huge beard
and he was like I don't know if this is
the guy
what is that it's a gun it's a [ __ ]
gun there's so much ambiguity in it
which I really loved you know it was a
it was a gangster movie but without the
gangsters you know it was it was about
violence but lacking violence it was a
really challenging challenging thing to
play because everything was so close to
the vest there everything was just this
kind of internal volcano that was
brewing inside that really rarely ever
had a moment to be let out but doing
those scenes with Jessica was just so so
much fun because we were very similar
animals ex machina one of the very first
auditions I had when I graduated from
school was for a movie called sunshine
that Alex Garland had written and I
remember reading the script and I just I
became so obsessed with it after I
didn't get the part I still would go
back and read it and I had all these
ideas for music and I remember being
like is there a way that I can get these
people my ideas because I've got some
really great thoughts about this thing
but that's how much of an impression
that the scripted made on mean years
later he was directing his first film
officially I went into this hotel to
meet him I remember as I was going in I
saw a number of actors leaving so it was
like the speed-dating thing that he was
doing huh and there was like oh hello
you yeah big big fan and then I'd go in
to go and talk to him we sat down and I
immediately started talking about
sunshine I'm also quite a bit of a nerd
and so you know I thought a lot about
consciousness and what consciousness
means and particularly in terms of
artificial intelligence and we just sat
for a few hours and and just talked and
talked about all the possibilities and
how you know how you would play a
character like this the the fact that
within the movie itself this guy is
playing a role he has to portray someone
that's a very specific character in
order for the experiment to go the way
he wants it to go but also at the same
time you know he kind of goes method
with it a little bit and he goes so deep
in that it's at a certain point you know
where is the role that he's playing
where is he really because he isn't he
is a nihilist he knows that the
singularity is coming that it's going to
be the end for us it's just a matter of
one
and if it's not him somebody else is
gonna figure this thing out
Ava I said stop and then I forget
exactly why I went down this road with
it but I just thought of Stanley Kubrick
a lot someone there's also quite
mysterious and genius and brilliant so I
listened over and over to this one
recording an interview of his from it
was a little the late 50s and so there's
something about his voice that I really
liked and so I started trying to play
with that voice and I actually used the
glass the kind of same shaped glasses
that he had so for me it was really with
Kubrick and then a lot my father but as
a doctor and he's an incredibly
intelligent guy but he's got a you know
a strange spiritual aspect to him as
well it's funking my dad came to visit
and there's a really great picture of me
and him playing chess on the set in the
corner and he's got a beard and glasses
and me no not shaved head but those were
kind of the two people that I really
thought of Star Wars The Force awakens I
was doing a most violent year and I
found out that JJ wanted to meet with me
for a part and that I needed to fly to
Paris and I remember I actually still
have the voice message saved because I
remember in between shooting that kind
of message from an unknown call caller
and it was a voice was like hey Oscar
it's JJ you know you don't have to come
all the way out to Paris what are you
getting what are you gonna do play a
droid you don't need to be doing that
actually this is Albert Brooks as Albert
was in movies so you really had me going
for a second there and I'm very happy I
still have that voice message but yes so
then I ended up going out to Paris and I
met with him and Cathy Kennedy and
Lawrence Kasdan and we sat in office and
they pitched me the story it's like this
we're all like guys first person he's in
the crawl you know they describe him
he's he's Leia's like number one pilot
and he shows up and you have a scene
with Max von Sydow and then then the the
main bad guy shows up and then and then
you die spectacularly I thought oh I
just I've done that so much where you
know you set up the main story for
the main characters you know so and then
Cathy to her credit she's like yeah you
did that for us in the Bourne Bourne
movie I was like yeah and I was like but
but let me let me think about it and
then I went home and kind of thought
about it I thought you know what I gotta
do this I gotta do it and then when I
called him to let him know I wanted to
do it he said actually we're changing it
up he's in the whole movie now it's
gonna be really cool you completed my
mission Finn that's my jacket
oh no no keep it it suits you
and I flew to London and I I read it
with John boyega that was first time
that I'd met him and the very next day
we were doing the the reading where we
were all sitting in a circle and reading
the new Star Wars movie star wars the
last Jedi for the force awakens uh you
know it was it was such a new thing it
was an incredibly huge moment so there
was just a very intense intense energy
it was excited but it just was there was
a vibration to the whole thing you know
and there was a every single thing was
so thought out and so orchestrated
because it meant so much in the second
one you know Ryan came in he was very
laid back I always described him as like
a West Coast jazz musician you know just
kind of loop is really cool and come up
and very quiet and soft-spoken and
humble and have like I had like a
childlike Wonder about the whole thing
and for me you know I got to to work
with laura dern who's one of my
favorites and and that was a that was a
fun thing to do and challenging as well
so yeah it was a it had a very different
energy the whole thing but yeah I was I
really really like Ryan apocalypse that
was excruciating I didn't know when I
said yes that that was what was going to
be happening that I was going to be
encased in glue and latex and in a
40-pound suit that I had to wear a
cooling mechanism at all times I
couldn't really move my head ever you
know I was like I get to work with these
like great actors that I like so much
but I couldn't even see them because I
couldn't move my head and I had to like
sit on a specially-designed saddle
because that's the only thing I could
really sit on and I'd just be put I
would be rolled into a cooling tent in
between takes and so I just wouldn't
ever talk to anybody and I'm just gonna
be sitting I couldn't really move and
like sweating inside the mask and the
helmet not answer them I'm happy
and then I was also in high heels inside
of a boot so that was very difficult to
move at all and every time I moved it
was just like rubbers and plastic
squeaking so everything I said had to be
dubbed later as well and then getting it
off was the worst part because they just
had to kind of like scrape it off for
hours and hours
so that was x-men apocalypse
annihilation that was a crazy experience
because I was shooting it last Jedi
exactly at the same time and on the same
lot in Pinewood so I would go back and
forth while I was doing Star Wars into
that really intense dark dark world and
that one had a because of that there's a
lot of found footage elements to it that
had a real looseness to it as well so we
would just play around with what that
was and oftentimes it would be Alex that
was operating the camcorder or a
flashlight and just kind of really
getting in there
that particular scene was pretty
astounding because they had you know
they actually made it practical there
was like a practical effect they had
kind of made this torso for the guy in
the flap that opens up and there was
someone behind them just pulling all
like the intestines and stuff and I just
remember again thinking of my father but
and everywhere because afterwards he
even pointed that out that there was
like the aw of of like cutting somebody
open and seeing something you know like
which made her more horrible as opposed
to me being kind of horrified by it I
was like up there yes you know there was
like an excitement to it which just made
it all the more disquieting so that's
something that Alex I talked a lot about
in that movie it's like how do you make
what's there it's just slightly off so
it just really creeps you out yeah that
was uh it was dark stuff but I loved
loved that movie